Sons keep it alive though Durant
trailing late of the play comes inside
of the first points and his son's
uniform for KD as he takes it right to
the rack for those smiles to be expanded
and he has KD getting his first bucket
in a son's uniform
Jimmy Williams their young player and
Richards a chance to get some minutes
Durant shows his defensive chops right
there gets the shot block
and turns to Hornets over
skip pass quick release threes coming
from Durant young player in Richards a
chance to get some minutes
Durant shows his defensive chops right
there gets the shot block
and turns the Hornets over skip pass
quick release three coming from Durant
Splashdown his first three-point attempt
KD and one thing he Prides himself on
and then trailer returning from that
groin injury
Williams inside and smothered chicken
for Durant as he pins the rookie on that
one
steps on defensively and distracts the
shoe to Rozier for the Miss controller
able to bounce back there but his son
jumped out to that nine nothing lead
a better job on the glass as well as
open up the second quarter with another
triple courtesy of KD
to dive to the basket they're going to
get open looks because he's getting
Double T but then you've got wide open
lanes and he'll find you
average almost six and a half assists
last year
[Applause]
[Music]
Duran Works off the screen raising up
from mid-range and that is the sweet
spot for Kevin Durant still left-handed
too he's able to just flip it up there
and then Durant
DeAndre Hayden checking back into the
game here with the Suns Durant gets
right of the lane little step back makes
the connection with the defender
it's on his hip he's pulling up that
little 15 footer it wasn't winding down
on them they had good looks
here is Duran
[Music]
float game in effect not a bad look 73
you're watching Phoenix Suns basketball
on Fout I think he's trying to get it up
on the backboard before the defense got
there
Juniors did one three looking for the
long one won't get it long rebound finds
Booker who brings the Boom
so this is all the bounce going right to
Kevin Durant and Booker releasing down
the floor
multi-talented play the piano the
saxophone trumpet
Durant gets to that elbow jumper with a
foul and the Finish from 17. for the
second year get a little bit anxious on
the defensive end we go at it
Tyrone Corbin on the bench with him
one of the Great sons is Durant again
mid-range game in effect
let's go for a nice position right here
Richards should have gotten a whistle
here's Durant gets to that left hand a
little ball fake money
rises above everybody and then he gets
by Blu-ray and kind of shakes off the
defense and goes up
false side up finds Durant
just that left hand goes to the pull-up
got it Chris Paul drew the double team
and then Durant one on one